c'est Mabrouk et député MoDem des
Hauts-de-Seine et président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale bienvenue sur
Europe 1 et bonjour Jean-Louis bourlant
bonjour Sonia
ukrainien zenenski a à Paris qui a
évidemment rencontré Emmanuel Macron
hier pour discuter des moyens et de
l'aide militaire supplémentaire à
l'Ukraine qui était à Rome puis Berlin
clairement on peut le dire c'est une
tournée diplomatique pour récupérer le
maximum d'armes avant une éventuelle
contrefensive il y a un HP veillée
d'armes effectivement dans tous les sens
du terme il faut avoir des armes et il
faut marquer et elle est tout à fait
réelle la solidarité des grands des
grands États européens qui sont derrière
l'Ukraine qui souhaitent que cet
offensive quand elle se déroulera soit
un succès et qui donc en temps d'assurer
par les les moyens qui sont les leurs
élanski de tout leur appui oui pour des
blindés des chars légers mais non pour
des avions de combat du côté de Paris
c'est un nom définitif ou si seulement
prématuré vous êtes quand même le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères à l'Assemblée donc vous êtes
aux avant-post sur libournange pour
savoir ce qui sera encore livré et
décidé
de la commission de la défense et les
forces armées et je me garderai bien
d'entrer dans les compétences qui sont
pas les miennes je ne sais pas du tout
ce que comment se doit se présenter ce
dossier ce dossier de l'aviation il me
semble qu'il y a deux considérations qui
sont d'ordinaires mises en avant la
première c'est que jusqu'à présent il
semble que les Ukrainiens ont une très
bonne maîtrise de leur ciel de leur mais
qu'il soit très exposé quand il survole
des terres contrôlées par les Russes et
nous vous donc on se demande à quoi
servirait exactement ces avions à court
terme la deuxième chose c'est que pour
mettre en
action de tel de tels matériels il faut
énormément de choses avant il faut de la
formation ce les matériels auxquels les
Ukrainiens ne sont pas habitués ils ont
travaillé sur des avions d'origine
soviétique c'est donc quelque chose de
tout à fait différent et ça ne pourrait
produire des effets que dans quelques
mois de toute manière il me semble pas
que ce soit le moins du monde lié au
calendrier de l'offensive qui s'annonce
aspect militaire et puis aspect
évidemment géopolitique Jean-Luc
bourlange dans une interview accordée au
journal l'opinion Emmanuel Macron
affirme que la Russie ne doit pas gagner
la guerre et qu'elle a déjà perdu
géopolitiquement c'est votre avis
écoutez oui c'est tout à fait c'est tout
à fait non seulement mon avis je crois
que c'est une opinion assez répandue
parmi les experts et les responsables
politiques Poutine a fait des choix qui
sont absolument désastreux pour la
Russie et le président le président de
la République montre très bien que en
réalité le seul bénéficiaire de tout ça
c'est la Chine ce qui d'ailleurs est
préoccupant moi je vois je discute
beaucoup avec des représentants de de la
scie centrale tous les stands ou même la
serbaïque Jean l'Arménie enfin tout pour
ce qu'on voit la Géorgie ce qu'on voit
c'est la présence accrue de la Chine sur
cette partie du monde qui singer disait
que
l'effondrement de la Russie ça serait
une sorte de gigantesque
effondrément de la Yougoslavie avec tous
les inconvénients qui s'y attachent donc
là véritablement Poutine à à très très
gravement desservie les intérêts de son
pays la Russie a donc aurait donc perdu
géopolitiquement mais c'est l'Occident
qui est engagé Jean-Luc bourlange au
côté de l'Ukraine pas le monde entier il
y a beaucoup d'autres pays qui sont
neutres et veulent leur rester pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en parle si peu
ils sont neutres mais que je voulais
nous on va pas quel que soit la
sympathique nous ayons pour la nos amis
Taïwan on va pas envoyer des troupes si
les Chinois
occupent Taïwan ou pourquoi voulez-vous
que il se passe
que les Africains les Indiens etc se
sentent directement concernés ils ont
leurs problèmes nous essayons de les
aider à les régler quand nous quand nous
le pouvons et nous avons une solidarité
Taïwan est un bon exemple représentant
de Taïwan à Paris disait écoutez moi
j'attends pas de Monsieur Macron qui
soit derrière Taïwan je sais qu'il a de
la solidarité pour le maintien de la
liberté dans cette île et de même je
suis extrêmement favorable à l'Ukraine
mais c'est pas de l'aide de Taïwan que
que le le salut de l'Ukraine viendra
donc nous sommes les premiers concernés
nous nous engageons fortement
insuffisamment les états insuffisamment
a suffisamment par rapport aux
États-Unis je veux dire que ce que je
veux dire c'est que nous sommes nous
faisons tous qu'il faut tout ce que nous
pouvons mais nous voyons bien que
nous Français que les Européens c'est
c'est pas un tigre du Bengal les
Européens c'est plutôt un chat de qui
découvrent la vie sauvage pas tout à
fait la même chose et on voit que
l'essentiel
américain que peut-on faire c'est quand
même le roi de la jungle géopolitique en
faire plus et c'est une souris
il s'agit pas d'envoyer plus de charpe
plus de choses on fait le travail mais
il s'agit de ce que les Européens se
dotent d'une capacité d'action militaire
beaucoup plus forte que celle qu'ils ont
depuis la guerre
c'est un plan assez inédit par rapport à
l'Ukraine et il faut dire que
l'Allemagne traînait un petit peu des
pieds est-ce que vous y voyez toujours
une timidité européenne par rapport à je
parle pas de timidité je crois que le
problème c'est le logiciel européen on a
bâti l'Europe pour la paix on a bâti
l'Europe pour éliminer la guerre on a
bâti l'Europe pour que les peuples
s'entendent on avait dit l'Europe pour
que l'Europe soit exemplaire
aujourd'hui le président de la
République a parlé de naïveté un moment
et il a raison alors nous autres
Français nous sommes sans doute et
personnellement depuis toujours je suis
comme vous savez un ardent favorable à
l'Union européenne et j'ai toujours dit
que ceux qui avaient été manqué après
Maastricht c'est pas la monnaie unique
c'est pas ça ce qui avait été manqué
c'est le passage à l'Europe puissance à
la politique étrangère commune à la
politique de défenseur comment sous le
parapluie qui américain mais notre
parapluie je suis désolé
la dissuasion
préfèrent le parapluie à américain
la force de dissuasion c'est d'abord la
protection du territoire français et on
voit quand même dans cette guerre à quel
point le fait de disposer de l'arme
nucléaire évidemment nous n'avons pas du
tout les moyens comparables à ce virus
mais le fait même de disposer de l'arme
nucléaire est un élément central de la
sécurité alors maintenant sur la
protection de de l'Europe on voit bien
que le temps qui était sans doute le
président à 8h de parler de mort
cérébrale il aurait peut-être été
préférable de parler de coma parce que
le coma on en sort et on en est sorti à
l'occasion de l'Ukraine à l'occasion de
la guerre du crâne et on voit bien qu'il
y a une solidarité organisée des
Européens face à des menaces russes et
on voit bien que compte tenu des
engagements américains dans le Pacifique
qui vont à les croissants la relève de
l'effort de guerre des Américains par
les Européens c'est une exigence pour
les 15 prochaines années le discours du
président français a évolué sans doute
de votre point de vue dans le bon sens
rappelons qu'Emmanuel Macron avait dit
qu'il ne fallait pas humilier la Russie
ce temps-là il est fini nous ne sommes
plus aujourd'hui dans avec ces mots
quand on lit l'interview du président
parce que je crois que la Russie c'est
humilié toute seule je veux dire
qu'est-ce qui est humiliant c'est
d'avoir une armée qui fonctionne comme
l'armée russe c'est la résistance
ukrainienne elle a fait son travail et
le problème c'est c'est c'est simplement
le moment venu que les Russes acceptent
de reconnaître leur erreur ce serait
évidemment plus facile pour quelqu'un
qui ne serait pas Vladimir Poutine de le
faire mais c'est pas à nous organiser la
succession en Russie jusqu'au faut-il
suivre Zelinski le président ukrainien
aurait eu je le mets vraiment au
conditionnel l'intention de mener des
attaques à l'intérieur de la Russie
selon le Washington Post au cours de
réunions il aurait proposé d'en veillir
des villages frontaliers ou de frapper
directement le sol russe alors ce sont
des révélations du renseignement
américain tout de suite démentie par
zenenski ce serait inquiétant de tels on
peut comprendre la tentation voilà un
peuple qui est agressé à partir d'un
voisin on lui dit vous avez le droit de
vous battre sur votre territoire de
devoir tuer vos concitoyens mais vous
n'avez pas le droit de mettre le pied
chez l'agresseur ça peut agaçant bon
maintenant la sagesse on la connaît la
sagesse et qu'il faut éviter que cette
guerre déborde que cette guerre qui est
une guerre terrible dégénère en conflit
mondial les américains ils veillent et
je crois que la gestion de toute cette
affaire par l'administration américaine
est assez remarquable heureusement qu'on
a Biden et patron c'est une gestion
cohérente prudente et en même temps très
solidaire et les Américains veillent
très très clairement à ce
qu'effectivement c'est débordements ne
se produisent pas et elle inscrit le
comprendre parfaitement même s'il a la
tentation d'en faire un peu plus
peut-être parce que les Américains
regardent surtout du côté de la Chine
voilà un autre conflit dont vous avez
parlé les Américains juste titre ne
veulent pas que cette guerre se traduise
par un renforcement considérable de la
Chine notamment dans toute la vie
centrale il paraît que il y a quelques
années le président de si a regardé la
carte du monde la star de la Chine de
l'URSS l'ancien URSS et à dire en voyant
la Sibérie a dit oh là là c'est grand et
c'est vide
ce sont des formules très inquiétantes
autre sujet de politique internationale
majeur Jean-Louis bollan qui se passe en
Turquie avec très probablement un second
tour inédit entre erdoğan au pouvoir
depuis près de 20 ans et son opposant et
qui dit chef daroglou pour erdouane ce
n'est pas tout à fait une victoire mais
il faut le dire certainement pas une
défaite comme certains l'annoncer en
Europe et puis en Occident ça fait un
règne elle n'est pas pour tout de suite
non
c'est vraiment pas une défaite je crois
que ça sera très très dur c'est très dur
d'imaginer que l'opposition puisse
gagner au second tour le
Erdogan a déjà imposé sa majorité
parlementaire puisque la cape sont
partis obtiendra une majorité assez
confortable une majorité donc nous ici
député de la majorité nous rêverions et
donc et en plus c'est assez difficile
d'imaginer que côtoyant de s'y prêt la
majorité absolue il la manque au second
tour mais enfin les électeurs peuvent
changer les électeurs peuvent se
mobiliser
consultons pas le peuple turc sur deux
malgré le tremblement de terre la
corruption tout ce qui lui est reproché
il se maintient c'est un c'est un succès
indiscutable
le ressort de la misère a été plus fort
que la dénonciation la misère face le
désarroi face au tremblement de terre a
été plus fort que la dénonciation de la
corruption la fièvre nationaliste qui a
accompagné ces dernières années
notamment le conflit ukrainien le rôle
indirect qu'il a joué dans mes forts le
double jeu entre les États-Unis et et la
Russie ont flatté certainement la le
sentiment national national turc je
crois que c'est très inquiétant
non pas que je critique a priori erdegan
mais je crois que la Turquie continue de
jouer cet entre deux
entre la Russie et l'Occident entre la
démocratie et la dictature entre
l'Europe et les Républiques et l'islam
l'islamisme militante elle ne choisit
pas et nous non plus ce qui m'inquiète
c'est quand on regarde des Européens on
s'aperçoit que les Français sont assez
fermes ils aident ils aident notamment
les Grecs à résister mais je sens pas du
tout cette fermeté et en Espagne ni en
Allemagne et en dehors de l'Union
européenne ni au Royaume-Uni donc on est
dans une situation énumère ni même en
Italie et des changements d'attitude de
temps en temps en Italie mais ça n'est
pas très clair et et là je pense que
nous avons un vrai problème au sein
les Européens à cause du problème
immigré car les Turcs peuvent à tout
moment libérer des vagues d'immigrés qui
submergeraient la Bulgarie à cause de
l'OTAN nous sommes dans une alliance
militaire et les Turcs
qu'on est tenu on est tenu par par notre
propre incision le problème des
Européens c'est qu'il faut qu'ils se
mettent d'accord entre eux et qu'ils en
tirent les conséquences nous ne sommes
faibles nous nous sommes faibles d'une
situation géopolitique très dure parce
que le les valeurs occidentales le
territoire d'influence de l'Occident est
une peau de chagrin depuis 30 ans qui se
rétrécit nous perdons les positions
partout mais nous sommes surtout fait
faibles de notre indécision de nos
divisions et de notre faible
mobilisation sont des enjeux de
puissance j'appelle vraiment les
Européens à ce à se redresser à se
mobiliser et à s'unir
ce matin une question sur la politique
intérieure à présent Jean-Luc bourlant
j'imiterai à préciser que vous êtes
aussi vous faites partie du MoDem
Emmanuel Macron affirme qu'il est
possible de réformer sans la loi puis un
peu plus loin dans cette interview dans
l'opinion il dit qu'il est possible de
bâtir des majorités mais non on les voit
pas vous les voyez vous vous le voyez le
chemin c'est très compliqué
transformé en la loi je crois assez
profondément à cette réalité parce que
je pense que le problème numéro un du
pays c'est le les dysfonctionnements de
l'appareil public de la bureaucratie et
ça implique beaucoup d'efforts de type
gouvernemental de type administratif et
assez peu de solutions générales
théoriques qui sont celles qu'on qu'on
apporte par la loi donc je pense qu'il y
a vraiment un champ d'action mais très
difficile parce que on se heurte à des
résistances partout syndicales humaines
psychologique partout or nous sommes en
situation de relatif faiblesse la
majorité il faut voir vous avez nous
vivons
si on a eu une seconde encore la
Cinquième République nous vivons trois
crises par rapport à la à la situation
qui a été créée les institutions créées
par le général de Gaulle et pas et et et
et assumé par Pompidou Giscard et
Mitterrand une première crise le non
renouvellement du mandat ça veut dire
que le président dans quatre ans mes
collègues moi je serai pas candidat mais
dans quatre ans mes collègues ne savent
pas derrière qui ils seront et ça ça
rend très très difficile pour le
président de faire un un redressement
c'est difficile de faire un virage quand
vous êtes dans une dans une circonstance
la deuxième majorité absolue et
troisièmement et c'est ça qu'il faut
voir c'est que nous n'avons pas une
alternative possible généralement on est
quand on est court on a ceux d'en face
et ça donne la cohabitation là nous
sommes dans un système ternaire si nous
avions une dissolution l'Assemblée qui
ressortirait serait sans doute encore
plus un gouvernable que celle
d'aujourd'hui donc nous avons trois
grandes difficultés comment s'en tirer
président en raison de dire par par
l'action non législative c'est important
et également par la recherche modeste de
de majorité difficile et ça ça implique
que les gens prennent le responsabilité
notamment du côté des socialistes
modérés et des et de LR quand la partie
de l'air qui n'est pas tentée par le
merci
d'être venu nous voir sur Europe 1 merci
Sonia